boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are still at Indy BIOS demo day number
eight we are now gonna be speaking with
Alex Lewis hello hey thanks so much for
coming absolutely my pleasure really
appreciate CEO of electroactive
technologies that's right yeah what was
what was the talk on the main yeah we
just you know all the companies anybody
give us seven minute pitch and for us
we're you know developing this modular
system to convert food waste into
renewable hydrogen which can powers your
mission vehicles you know going into the
future here and so we're yeah developing
this kind of local urban solutions food
waste produced in the city can stay in
the city to make fuel that can be used
to power a zero emission transportation
in the city so Lou yeah looking to make
everything more sustainable and find a
better use of food waste which is us you
know forty percent of food is wasted
it's a crazy amount and so we're you
know we're trying to find a higher
values of that which we think can you
know turn into zero emission fuels you
know at an economical price yeah when I
saw what you guys are doing out there it
totally spoke to me as the future of
cities and the future of sustainable
ecosystems in general yeah so okay so
let's walk through this so we have
something like our compost first of all
the statistic is crazy forty percent
yeah I mean it's crazy yeah just up and
down the supply chain you know it starts
at the farm happens in transport happens
at the restaurant
businesses and then in the home it's
just across the board you know forty
percent is lost or you know close to
forty percent you know it depends on the
country but it's it's it's a it's a high
mountain yeah yeah in supermarkets yeah
although always anyone that has food
food or selling food it's you know it's
happening but down supply chain that's
why it's so high Andes yeah in the homes
window in the fridge we yeah that's the
biggest thing this chunk is in the home
yeah in the restaurants interesting okay
and then so okay so and then um that's
getting okay so first of all we gotta
live in cities where we're composting
more like the fact that we still some
cities only have like garbage yep don't
even recycling yep and then you gotta
add the last yeah and then we got to do
things like the biodegrade farmers to
not even have some of the issues yes yep
as well okay and then we take compost
and then you have this what what do you
call the modular what do you call that
yeah it's it's I guess you we refer to
as a stack because we're stacking
together our reactors to make a larger
stack and so we had this
our system is called the eh to Jen which
is you know a kind of a combination of
our names here but but it's a this
modular system that can really you know
give it some flexibility about where it
can be placed into what scale because a
lot of the solutions typically need this
huge plant that has to be located a long
distance away but our modular system can
then be you know plugged into cities at
different spots and plop down wherever
it's needed so it gives a lot more
flexibility to go where the problem is
okay so this modular system right now is
small and comes yeah but eventually you
see it as yes so a small prototype about
this size but we're looking at is more
like a shipping container size unit
which would have thousands of our cells
in there and that can be dropped down
and scaled you know up or down from that
point to to meet the needs how much
waste there is how much hydrogen that
could be used let's look at some
facility let's get into the technicality
so okay so we take this forty percent of
food waste all right and then what are
we doing with the compost into the
module yeah and so right now like in
California luckily they're you know
ahead of the curve and are and already
have that third collection and most of
it goes to composting but it has to be a
lot of times they're still trucked out
200 miles from where it's produced and
so getting it to compost and doing that
is good but it's you know they're it's
not it's it's a starting point and so
for us and it's also really inefficient
because only a fraction of what's in
that food waste ends up being in the
compost and so our process being located
you know closer to the city can take
that food waste
suck out a lot of the liquid insoluble
compounds that we use to make hydrogen
and then the smaller amount that's left
over can be sent on to composting which
is a smaller amount less trips out there
and it's also just a better input for
composting so it can really improve the
entire chain while getting a lot more
value out of it and then what are we
doing with because we've seen now yeah
the mass of going and getting tours if
it's actually really enlightening the
garbage recycling and composting
facilities when you're there and then
you like for example you guys take and
blend the compost and then you feed it
yeah and we are focusing on the food
waste aspect our goal is to get to the
municipal stage where there's you know
there's paper or other compostable
things in there and so it'll be pre
processed and that a lot of that stuff
will just come through and come out
because we're taking a liquid fraction
out of that and so when we do that
pre-processing step this other stuff
that's destined for composting will kind
of come through and not go into our
system
take the liquid part out that comes from
the food waste and that's what gets feds
into our system and we have microbes
that grow in there that are able to
degrade that waste and extract energy
out of that which we use to make
hydrogen
okay so let's so keep going with this
process so we have how do we feed
blended compost into those so this is
like a soil that has microbes in it yeah
so that's we that's where we kind of
originally get some of the microbes is
these all the microbes we have our Prima
are pretty much naturally occurring in
soil but we've taken it out and kind of
directed them towards the function we
want to have it happen and so they'll be
break these microbes exist in soil to
break down you know leaves and things
that happen okay we've taken those and
really concentrated them and enhance
their functions in our reactor so they
can just get waste break it down and we
can take the energy from it okay so as
the microbes the concentration of
microbes is breaking down this blend yet
waste they're producing electricity yeah
it's it sounds strange and but there's a
special class of microbes that again we
haven't genetically engineered they're
out there in the soil where they
typically work to reduce iron and other
metals that are in soil because when you
start breaking things down just
naturally cycles there has to be a place
for you to to dump the electrons that
come off in these reactions so not to
get too technical but there's these
microbes that instead of producing a gas
or breathing or passing electrons to air
to make co2 they can just pass the
electrons directly to a metal or carbon
and so we grow the microbes on an
electrode where they can just pass the
electrons directly and so they work with
the other microbes breaking down the
food waste and we just accept the
electrons as they're produced and so the
microbes grow on that collector and we
just take the electrons as they're
produced and use them to make hydrogen
on the other side of the reactor and so
there's a lot happening in this little
compact reactor whoa okay the microbes
are right on the alekhya so they're
passing right as they're going through
how to process with the foodways
yeah passing the electron through the
lecture and then you guys how do you
then in this closed system turn that
into yeah so yeah so our reactor is
actually two chambers there's two sides
the reactor you think there's a sandwich
there's two sides and separated by some
cheese but for us as a membrane and so
we have a membrane separating the two
sides microbes are going on one side
eating the waste making all those
electrons
there passed to the other side which
were just an electrochemical reaction
happens with a metal catalyst and so the
electrons that come off in protons that
also come off go to their side and they
make hydrogen okay in electrochemical
reality and electrochemistry to make the
hydrogen whoa yeah it's just all in the
small little stag eat and that we okay
and then and then okay so with the the
and the electrochemical reaction leaves
you with hydrogen yeah pure source your
honor Hydra yeah and that's the benefit
for our system where because we have
these two sides of the reactor so the
hydrogen being produced is kind of
separated because the microbes still
they do produce co2 and other gases okay
but so it's good that are the hydrogen
reaction is happening separate from that
and so that way all those gases other
things that are happening on the
microbial side is separated from the
reaction that makes hydrogen so we have
a pure reaction of hydrogen being made
there which you know it's really
beneficial for downstream processing and
purification where you know it's a much
simpler thing to do yeah and then
there's even potentially a way to
capture this yeah yeah and we're working
on making that also very pure stream
where ya back this renewable source of
co2 could could be used another
application could end up being another
revenue stream for us whoa so so blended
compost from are like offices and homes
and these commercial sites and all these
places farms all these places can then
be used to feed microbes will eat on
that produce electricity that we can
then use as hydrogen power to then power
the electricity in our homes or in our
cars or all different yeah in transport
we see is where the initial benefits
would be because batteries in the
electric cars are great but they have
some limitations and there needs to be
you know what it's you know some
additional options out there with
batteries and electric vehicles are
great but you have the low low range
can't drive the same distance as normal
cars and it's a longer refueling process
so fuel cell cars you have the same
experience of gasoline and diesel cars
just the same amount of range rapid
refueling but it's an electric vehicle
still just runs on hydrogen and so those
benefits are really even more so for the
heavy duty vehicles big trucks and buses
if you uh you know the transit fleets
here in San Francisco have fuel cell
buses in their in their mix and so
that's where we see you know the initial
markets happening are in those
heavy-duty areas but hydrogen can also
be used in a fuel cell to
make electricity for homes and other
areas but with cos electricity being
pretty low from solar and wind you know
electricity will pop look normally
tricity probably still be the main trend
where hydrogen comes into play on that
and actually it's cuz while we'll feed
what food waste is our feedstock there's
also you know a strong amount that's
coming from electricity as well so
microbes make electrons we also take
external electrons to make hydrogen it's
not just the electrons from food waste
we take in additional electricity input
from like solar or wind and so as solar
and wind continue to grow it's it's
produced at times and people don't use
it and it goes to waste and so you need
to be able to store or store that
electricity and that's what we can do
with ours it could store it as hydrogen
and it can be and can sit there until
you need it and can be turned back into
electricity to use in cities or can go
into transport and so it's it's a really
versatile way to store and carry energy
and it's you know does so it in a zero
emission you know fashion and so it's
really you know it's really you know
changing the landscape of energy ok so
you would also potentially on these
commercial sites or residential sites or
farm sites that you would have solar and
wind power potentially as well in these
sites and then when what happens
sometimes is when you're when your
capacity is full on energy storage you
need to then convert that electricity
into hydrogen fuel cells and that's
where you guys could help yeah yeah it's
more with the city scale as well we're
looking at California specifically they
I mean they curtailed a crazy amount of
electricity last year where you know
that could that could power more than
the entire hydrogen market where this is
as much electricity is going to waste
because there it's produced at times and
people don't use it
and right now battery storage is just
too expensive and it can only be you
know for a two hour period when you use
the electricity to make hydrogen it can
sit there for days and months and then
be used when needed so there's like
seasonal storage
shoo-shoo in wind or solar light with
the battery we that that electrical
charge is only good it's only good for a
short amount of time or if it's you once
you charge the battery it starts to
dissipating over time and then once you
start using it it's gone within two
hours and so it's really say with
electric car it's kind of a dynamic
thing where it's you know short-term low
range which is really good for Rapid
Response but as as you know renewable
like tricity becomes like 50% of the mix
you know instead of five the amount of
storage you need you know over the long
term is high and only
can really provide that kind of storage
where it can sit and it doesn't go
anywhere it doesn't you don't lose the
energy and it can be turned back in so
there's all these multi-pronged benefits
from hydrogen that's it's it's
interesting yeah that when the hydrogen
works really well as a store over time
yeah that's and you can use it in
transport for the vehicles or you can
use it in fuel cell to turn it back in
Vleck tricity for a building and so yeah
it has transport you it can also be used
you know down the line instead of
natural gas hydrogen can be used in the
home for you know heating and cooking as
a gas this is a gas and so we can
replace natural gas long-term in in
those type of applications as well so it
really has reduced ability to
decarbonize the entire you know spectrum
of the economy so there's a lot of a lot
of a lot of momentum behind hydrogen but
still a lot of work to go to you know to
bring it to the to the masses and then
you see the modular unit that you're
putting together but you're seeing it
both iterating over time to make it more
and more efficient the processes but
also then in terms of size you see it
potentially on each individual like home
or business or do you see one in a big
community yeah we see we see it more at
the community level but you know
long-term as you know as the cost of
everything starts to come down and
things change it could certainly
potentially be in the home but right now
you know community level or at this at
the stage where you know these huge
apartment complexes that are here at
that kind of level the amount of waste
in all the homes within that big complex
and building would be enough you know at
an area where you have a small radius of
you know 10 restaurants you know a
couple block radius at that kind of you
know network scale is what we're looking
at to be at the community level and have
these positioned to to take the waste in
a small radius to avoid you know right
now you know as I mentioned the food
weighs getting trucked out 200 miles
you're also trucking in fuel from
hundreds of miles keeping it all in this
kind of network you know reduces cost
but it also makes the whole system more
robust where you know there's not one
thing that gets knocked out or goes if
there's a problem disrupts the entire
thing if you have multiple sites all
around it kind of creates a better you
know smart city as we talked about the
beginning just a smart sustainable city
yeah and then just another thought is as
an input is compost like blended compost
I mean if we're really smart so
we won't have compost right we would
yeah yes so then what would be like an
oven yeah and so there's you know and as
a public benefit corporation where you
know we support you know just food waste
not going to waste and some that's
edible getting to people in need to be
able to use that and but unfortunately
there's such a substantial amount that
can't be safely recovered that there's
really no pathway to have no no food
surplus any point so we'll always have a
feedstock on that end
but there's other other things that can
go into it as well we're you know
working with testing animal manure and
other things that you know it could be
an input that's anything organic can
really go in there you know the the big
big the other things that change is how
much you have to pre-process it if you
took a tree which is organic it will
require a lot more pre-processing to get
to a liquid so starting with food waste
is you know is the you know is a big
problem on its own and there's a best
starting point for us you can also take
waste water which has a lot of organics
in there as well so it's really any
organic feed could come in there food
waste is you know it's a big problem and
starting point for us that we want to
address yeah this these I'm super
excited to see what other combinations
of like modular units for sustainability
and in future cities that we're gonna
move towards these are very exciting
yeah yeah there's there's a lot of cool
things being done on that realm that we
really want to partner up and pair with
you know it's just being a part of that
solution for how all these you know all
the all the ways that seas are becoming
smarter and integrating things that we
always want to be a part of that
solution and contribute to that so it's
it's really exciting the things that are
happening that area would be cool to see
kids also growing up seeing these and
playing with them yeah and that's one of
the things we're looking at actually for
for pilots is some of these elementary
schools and high schools are actually
pretty self-motivated to implement their
own composting programs even though
they're not required to yet and they're
doing that and so we're looking at you
know doing pilots there where we can do
these demonstration units where the
small amount of hydrogen produced at
that scale could be used instructionally
to talk about fuel cells and and get you
know the kids next generation kids
excited about you know engineering in
these clean tech areas and so yeah it'd
be great to get these deployed at
schools and and and yeah start start the
exposure early to really because that's
where it requires is you know people who
are just used to that kind of lifestyle
and just you know they'll grow up and
think way people didn't use to compost
like why would lies
why would that ever happen and so that's
what we're kind of going towards and
schools are you know they're you're a
great place to start doing things yeah
that's a huge question is that where
we're in 50 years are we gonna look and
say I can't believe we were doing those
archaic hahaha that's a really good way
to realize what we need to be doing
today yeah absolutely absolutely thanks
for coming on to the show yeah I
appreciate it was great track with the
oh yeah usually yeah well the check in
again you know later on and sue a wrap
yeah exactly we love doing updates too
absolutely I would love for everyone to
check out the links in the Bible Oh
electroactive technologies again you
could find the link in the Bible go and
support them check them out
I'll check out Indy bio as well check
out that link in the bio below have more
conversations to your friends families
co-workers people online on social media
about things like we discussed in this
episode and support the artists
entrepreneurs the organizations around
the world in building the support
simulation our links are below as well
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thanks for tuning in
we'll see you soon peace